we talk about why someone would try to
sabotage their careers or maybe just the
specific situations you found yourself
in um yeah I encountered that with a lot
of people even people that not in a
movie is that it's it's almost like when
you get something you always sense that
well you have this kind of instinctive
behavior that like you know what let me
just like ruin it let me sabotage what's
happening with it why is that happen I
don't know I'm not a psychologist I
don't know what what's the root of that
behavior but some people get restless
and in the town it's almost like I think
they go into business and they think
that if they get work that it's going to
be a constant creativity and I think
when people start to realize that it's
really almost a business where it's
stagnant you know I mean you know like
doing a movie it's not like I own stage
and you get to be yourself or you get to
be the character but it's really from
you know you stand here move over there
cut it's like it's very tedious and I
think people get burned out so I guess
maybe that's what leads to the sabotage
I don't know but I've always seen that
tend to be people get restless and they
just don't want to do it and they start
to pass on projects they start to get
very irritated they start to feel like
they just don't want to talk to people
they don't want to deal with it and it's
the same thing for actors and filmmakers
so you just get very J but I don't know
if I've never had the sabotage thing I
think it's because I think anybody gets
into filmmaking you're really more
willing I guess it's more work not
saying that it's more work you know
being a filmmaker than an actor but it's
almost like you have to you're shooting
your recording audio you're editing it's
if you pass that period I don't think
when somebody pays you they the sabotage
exists as much as with the actors it's
like I think they actually get very
comfortable once they get a lot of work
and then they get burned out and then
they start to like just
retaliate in a way but not all
so at some point you said I'm leaving LA
and did you destroy the film first or
did you leave la first no I destroyed
the film when I moved because I again I
took the boxes with me and I was
thinking all right you know I mean it's
my father Trey as I figured out just
hold on to it maybe somebody will call
but nobody called and then it got to a
point I felt like staring at the debt
that the film reels was almost like too
depressing that I felt like okay in
order to move on from here to here I
need to just kind of wipe this off it's
because you know you leave town then you
have you still have your film with you
and it has that association with you I
felt like if I got rid of it I would
reset
how did you feel once you knew that the
film was destroyed oh just you know but
it was already destroyed in a sense of
like it wasn't going to come out so in
my mind it was already done and but I
felt like he just was deliberating to
just get rid of that car completely you
know it was like a truck load where you
would think like just one kind of your
movies like yeah because like tons of
reels and audio and all that stuff but
it did have back in the vault i think
was stacked in here in in 11 of the
involved places that you rent by the
year like very cheap that that some of
the original tapes were still sitting
here which i completely even did it
remember and because you're always
making duplicates and so there was a
whole set in here in LA but not there
was no cut of the movie like not carving
just that was the raw footage she was
here
so you destroyed the film you're out of
California how are you be building your
mindset because I'm sure when you get to
that point there's like this bitterness
and you just want to give up on
everything how did you rebuild your
mindset so you felt refreshed what's I
it's more of the dashing yourself from
that project it's almost like you become
more this it's like a dog and a bone as
you know it's like it's this product
you're always staring at are you always
thinking about it and it's like you have
to get to a point where you go okay this
is one project it's like if I made this
one project that make another one so you
just have to completely like just like
get rid of it and that was just more of
separating myself from it then it's my
question yeah so then how do you come
back to it and make my big break um once
I felt clear once I felt clear and I let
go of that of carving of what happened
with carving then I was like you know if
I did the first one I could do it I
could do it again and i had i think once
i realized who they actually had more
instead of just the tellin telling them
for actors story adding the filmmaking
process in the film that that would make
actually the movie better than carving
and i think that's what kind of ignited
that excitement in my mind and I was
like oh it's like I have a better
project than what I had before so then
that kind of
you know made me feel like I should do
this now so when carving you you weren't
part of these no i wasn't i didn't even
speak in carving I didn't narrate I
didn't appear I was almost I was the
camera you know but then once years have
passed I wanted to update on the guys
see what happened with everyone I mean
just tell what happened with everyone to
a certain degree and and I felt like I
be also interesting to kind of give
people a sense of like you know you
would get two things in the movie you'll
get the filmmaking process and the
acting process before during after oh
just being here for years and do working
on something just something will be
honest and truthful and also I felt like
if I'm going to tell a story about the
guise of like the rise the fall the
doubt I would be fair to them to
actually tell my own figure and doubts
and
you know success and failure etc that
would be good
you